les gilets jaunes qui se présentaient
comme des révoltés cetera
tous les médias pour eux pendant très
longtemps regardez il ya une vague
regarder sur les radios en continu on
n'avait jamais vu ça
jamais vous aviez déjà vu à la
télévision du matin au soir
du matin au soir d'abord des
manifestations de gilet jaune en direct
pendant toute la journée
jamais j'ai vu ça oui j'ai participé à
des manifestations n'étaient un million
un million et demi de mieux en mieux et
ça faisait dix minutes à la rencontre
ça vous même quand ils étaient 60 même
quand il était va sur apple et y avait
que ça la seleçao lancer tous les débats
rouge à cause des chaînes d'info
continue on fait bien qu'elle montre
bien que jeunes et dans tous les débats
où j'ai été pendant quelques mois
partout il veut gilet jaune
enfin la summer fonctionne avec un ou
deux bons donc on peut pas dire non là
au monde
je dirais qu'il ya un phénomène
d'unanimisme condamnable mais
l'unanimisme la a été plutôt favorable
au gilet jaune
je sais que faut pas dire ça mais je
vous vois venir ici mais vous dites
qu'on a fait cadeau du peuple l extrême
droite
dans votre livre est ce qu on a pas que
je fais on a fait cadeau du peuple avec
l'extrême droite
est ce qu'on a fait a fait cadeau des
villes et jaune à l'extrême droite aussi
en leur reprochant d'être des factieux
d'être antisémite d'être homophobe et
c'est c'est eh ben pas une manière de
les jeter de les précipiter dans les
bras de l'extrême droite l'homme héros
il ya des c'est le gouvernement qui a
essayé de faire mais c'est pas dans
l'ensemble les médias mais en plus en
plus extraordinaires parce que je vois
par exemple le type le plus à droite de
tous les journalistes du figaro ivan
rioufol est un fanatique des gilet jaune
et le mec le plus à gauche de tous les
gens lisent de marianne est un fanatique
des gilet jaune ya aussi ce phénomène
jusqu'à quand même qu'on a vu qu'on
avait absolument jamais vu et entre nous
il ya cette convergence
une des raisons pour laquelle j'étais
réticent
par rapport au gilet jaune cc c'est
qu'on voyait cette convergence la dent
dans mon part entre nous
vous dites que vous avez là que en fait
les légines aujourd hui comment la
pensée unique contre eux alors que moi
je vous dis il ya eu il ya eu une pensée
unique que je revienne au jeu vous donne
un exemple personnel
il ya eu 12 livres qui sont parues
jusqu'à présent absolument enthousiastes
projet les jaunes mais comment je le
sais parce que j'ai écouté à france
inter à france culture
ils étaient invités etc moi je sais le
premier livre qui est critique vis-à-vis
des gilet jaune s'est invitée nulle part
ailleurs serra niveau bas c'est quand
même un bon s'est invitée c'est un bon
exemple
et en plus parce qu'il faut quand même
que je le dis devant vous parce que vous
pouvez vous pouvez me confortez 6 à
quelqu'un qui aurait eu des raisons
d'être projet les gens de chez moi pas
moi en tant dedans quand je dirigeais
marianne et tout ce qu'on a dit dans
marianne est quasi fois quelquefois seul
et quelquefois on en prenant plein la
gueule
c'est vraiment ce que les jets les
jaunes ont essayé de porter
[Musique]